bon je retienne un badge up merci de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
ce matin le jour à d'après sera de
droite comme le jour d'avant
c'est la réaction sur twitter des
manuels fort le premier secrétaire de
votre parti le ps après la nomination de
jean castex pourtant alex fidèles l'ex
fidèles du socialiste alain bertrand
delanoë nicolas revel prend les
commandes du cabinet du premier ministre
il y aura la droite et la gauche le en
même temps de d'emmanuel mâcon sont
mieux respectés non non il n'est dans un
virage clairement à droite et sa tournée
juste que le grand revirement n'aura pas
lieu moi que je pense que c'est surtout
un caprice du petit prince qui ne
voulaient pas qu'on fasse de l'ombre
il remplace edouard fini qu'on y peut
quelque part être un successeur
puisqu'il aurait pu rassembler toute la
droite pour un technocrate qui
finalement ne me frappe c'est une bande
d'ados donc vous sous-entendez que jean
castex est un exécutant
bien sûr c'est un technocrate vous savez
on est habitué à ce que emmanuel macron
est empli ait besoin d'être seul ou
ploie là aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'il fait
on est dans une personnalisation
absolument malsaine du mois et qui va
mener encore une fois ne pas écouter la
crise sociale ne pas écouter est le
besoin de renouvellement hockey exprimé
notamment les français lors de ces
municipales est une bague de gauche qui
a édicté quand même assez importante sur
la gauche rassemblée et lui il nous
choisi un ancien collaborateur de
nicolas sarkozy d'une chaîne reste à
droite où vous parlais justement de
dialogue social pourtant hier jean
castex lors de sa première interview à
fixer certaines priorités dont le
dialogue social est également lé plan de
relance économique et l'écologie qu'est
ce que vous attendez de son discours
politique générale attendue pour le
milieu de la semaine prochaine au
parlement
il sera il sera indéniablement dans la
continuité de ce qui a été fait lorsque
vous choisissez pour succéder à un homme
de droite un autre homme de droite que
voulez vous on en attendre on a essayé
de nous faire croire au tout début de
quinquennat qui avait ni droite ni
gauche
cette espèce dans le même temps a été
complètement emportées par les
différentes mesures qui ont été prises
par notre gouvernement et par emmanuel
macron plus personne ne pense d'ailleurs
regardez les sondages que m la
république en marche et amis partis de
droite toutes les alliances été fait ou
toujours été fait dans la quasi majorité
des villes avec des républicains
sincèrement que vous voulez vous que moi
femme de gauche je puisse attendre d'un
discours de général d'un premier
ministre de droite
le premier conseil des ministres de jean
castex a lieu mercredi
quel visage malgré tout est ce que vous
voudriez voir à ses côtés notamment je
pense au portefeuille de l'écologie du
travail de l'économie des affaires
sociales des domaines clés pour votre
parti le ps est ce qu'il peut y avoir un
compromis qui puisse satisfaire les
forces de gauche c'est à dire d'avoir à
la fois des visages de la droite issu de
la société civile par exemple
sincèrement je ne sais pas jusqu'ici
toutes les nominations ont été vaines
je vous rappelle que nicolas hulot qui
était quand même des grandes figures de
l'écologie a lui-même démissionné de ce
gouvernement parce qu'il considérait que
le compte n'y était pas vous pouvez y
prendre des hommes des femmes soit
disant de gauche mais dans un parti de
droite veut rester à droite la réalité
donc en choisissant apprenants de
ministres clairement encarté à droite
parce que c'est l'héritage de nicolas
sarkozy qu'il est empreinte de de
pérenniser mais on le fait avec
quelqu'un qui est interdit à quelqu'un
qui ne lui aura pas demande et donc on
revient à cet aspect est très jupitérien
quelle qu'elle soit selon vous pour les
dossiers chauds actuellement avec cette
nomination je pense au c ur de la santé
la réforme des retraites d'ailleurs pour
laquelle emmanuel macron hier dans la
pqr
dit souhaiter une nouvelle concertation
avec les partenaires sociaux je pense
aussi à l'économie post crise sanitaire
le souci c'est que avec tout ce qui
s'est passé avec cette crise sanitaire
on aurait pu espérer que la banque par
exemple dans le trade soit complètement
abandonné nous sommes dans un système
qui est mal mal ficelé retoquée par le
conseil constitutionnel et l'abandonné
et d'accompagner nos compatriotes dans
un temps peut-il vraiment difficile
puisqu'on et moscou et demi avec cette
crise sociale il va s'accroître
malheureusement est normalement l'ordre
de l'état c'est de protéger le mode de
l'état c'est d'accompagner et je ne
pense pas que dans les personnes qui
vont être nommés quelle qu'elle soit
elles seront déjà forcément à droite et
une personne de gauche qui cautionnerait
de participer à ce gouvernement revenir
a forcément ses attaches à gauche moi ce
n'est pas possible
compatible on ne peut pas digne de la
gauche dans un gouvernement et dans un
exécutif qui est viscéralement de droite
dernière question geslin bas diop cette
nomination intervient à moins de deux
ans de l'élection présidentielle de 2000
22 olivier faure le secrétaire général
de votre parti le ps a dit qu'il serait
prêt à se ranger derrière un candidat
vert
le ps at il encore les moyens de se
poser en alternative crédible à la
république en marché au rassemblement
national il le fait il l'a fait pendant
les municipales je vous rappelle que
leur la gauche qui a gagné c'est le
levant ce n'est pas la vague s'est pas
seulement les écologistes et avant tout
la gauche fera sans doute ont ils dit on
le répète et la gauche rassemblée qui
durait de l'alternative est ce que dit
le premier secrétaire est déviée fort
débat qu'il se rangera derrière
l'écologiste il dit qu'il est prêt à se
ranger derrière quelqu'un de la société
civile d'un autre parti dont les
écologies si un ou une socialiste
n'était pas la mieux placée
mais je vous invite à garder mon
résultat nous restons la première force
de gauche nous sommes les acteurs du
rassemblement et nous entendons bien
rester le parti historique que nous
avons toujours été
merci des beaux diables d'avoir répondu
à la question je rappelle que vous êtes
porte parole du parti socialiste